should I drop out of school to start my
business I got a question today this is
an important one from one of my
newsletter readers Jamar I'm gonna read
it to you guys and I have one question
to ask if you don't mind I'm stuck
between two goals I'm 32 years old and I
have all the drive and resources to
start a business as an online marketer
but I but I work as a paralegal and have
one more year left in college all my
friends around me are saying just
finished school but I disagree and want
to start focusing on one thing my
business because I'm realizing that I
can't do both school and business at the
same time what are your thoughts on this
Jamar this is a really tough one okay I
don't want to be the guy who says drop
out of school go do your business but I
find that whenever you're faced with an
important life decision and this is not
just businesses anything any important
decision in your life you want to make
it using your heart and not your head
the reason is your head is limited your
head is limited by the world that
currently exists right now where your
heart can create a new world for you if
you look at entrepreneurs who've started
successful businesses if they just
listen to their head if they listen to
their friends that they listen to the
world that was currently available to
them they would have never been
successful because what they created was
not possible the world that they created
for themselves the business they created
previously was not possible and if they
listened to their head they would never
have started that business where your
heart your passion can create something
it can create a new reality that didn't
exist before so you want to do things
because it's the right thing to do
because you were meant to do it because
you feel it and that comes from your
heart not because it makes logical sense
to do it this is why if you're really
good at math but you love drumming and
everybody says you should go and become
an accountant then go to school and
become an account because you're really
good at math and that that's
logical makes sense smart thing to do
smart thing to do but then you get stuck
on this career path in this job that you
hate wishing there was more to your life
because you were following what made
sense what your head set to do what was
logical because you can't make money as
a drummer you can you can find a way if
that's your passion you know they're
gonna make more money but you're gonna
be way happier in that path and it takes
a lot of guts and a lot of courage to
trust your heart so whatever you're
feeling right now you have this big
decision ahead of you trust your heart
and all your major life decisions come
from that now a couple of the things
from this email your friends you
shouldn't care what your friends think
and I know that's hard to say and it's
even harder to act on because these are
the people around you these are the
people who who you have to listen to if
your peer group doesn't support you you
need to move on and I know your friends
a lot of them are there they're
genuinely worried for you
like they're there thinking with their
heads - right they're thinking this
isn't the right thing to do
they're worried for you you're gonna
have others who are jealous of you they
hate their own career path and I don't
want you to they don't want to see you
get so far ahead of them so they're
jealous and they want to hold you back
either way you can't listen to your
friends you have to trust what's here
you have to trust that you're doing the
right thing and that may mean alienating
some of your friends but they weren't
the right friends for you anyway now
this would be a good test because the
friends who are true friends are gonna
be the ones who stick by you no matter
what who you say I'm doing this
whichever path you take I'm doing this
and see if they support you or not
because your best friends are gonna be
the ones who try to help you and find
ways for you to get to your goal in
aren't the ones who see you struggle and
say you see I told you so
you shouldn't have done that that was
stupid that's not a real friend
so stop caring about what your friends
think and do this for you how I would
handle this situation if I was picking
between online marketing is a biz
and finish in my school I would prove it
to myself I would prove to myself that I
really love this thing you know you're
saying that you can't be an online
marketer part-time of course you can
that's what most of these guys got
started this is the business to be in
part-time that get started
prove to yourself that if you spent one
hour a day okay one hour a day working
on your online marketing business prove
yourself two things okay one that you
are making money doing this right you're
gonna make money doing this and two that
you love doing this I don't want you to
leave your school leave your job jump
into this thing that you thought you
were gonna like and then it's not what
you thought at all and you hate it and
you have to go back and get back into
school and go back and get that job
prove to yourself try it every day one
hour get results show that you like it
show that you this is the path for you
and when you feel it then you can make
the decision you know what this this
this is okay I'm gonna be okay I'm gonna
follow this path and I'll be successful
and if you can't make it work off to the
one hour a day and you start hating it
then you know that that's not the path
for you either and probably this
paralegal thing to be honest it's not
gonna work out for you because you're
already drifting you're still in school
you're still trying to figure out what
you're gonna do you're drifting if your
mind is drifting to something else then
what you're doing right now is not the
path that's gonna support you and maybe
it's online marketing maybe it's
something else but you have to find that
because I want you to live a life that's
full of passion where you're making a
difference where you have an impact
where you're following your dreams and
it's okay to start part-time but don't
give up the search if it's not online
marketing is something else keep
searching until you find it believe for
those of you watching like the video
give it a thumbs up below you have a
comment you want to share your story you
have a question for me leave it below
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
if you like the videos they
so much I don't see you soon